♪
>> DO YOU HAVE PLANS TO VISIT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> I HAVE BEEN THERE BEFORE AND
I HAVEN'T -- I MEAN I KNOW IT
WELL.
I GUESS I SHOULD GO DOWN BUT --
BUT THE WHOLE POINT OF IT IS I
HAVEN'T HAD A WHOLE HELL OF A
LOT OF TIME TO GET DOWN.
>> THERE HAS BEEN REPORTING THAT
HE DID DRY THROUGH THE BORDER
WHEN HE WAS ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL IN 2008.
HE DOES NOT NEED A VISIT TO THE
BORDER TO KNOW WHAT A MESS WAS
LEFT BY THE LAST ADMINISTRATION.
>> Bret: THE WHITE HOUSE SAYING
HE DROVE PAST THE BORDER DURING
THE 2008 CAMPAIGN AND AND SAYING
EVEN THOUGH HE SAID THAT MAYBE
HE SHOULD GO DOWN THAT HE DIDN'T
REALLY MEAN THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
THAT TOWN HALL THAT HE WOULD GO
DOWN.
TOWN HALL NEEDED TO BE CLEANED
UP TODAY BY THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY IN A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT POINTS.
MEANTIME GALLUP, THE APPROVAL
ANALYSIS FOR GALLUP SAYS THAT
THE BIDEN'S AVERAGE THIRD
QUARTER JOB APPROVAL RATING IS
DOWN 8 POINTS FROM HIS SECOND
QUARTER 53%, 11 POINTS FROM HIS
FIRST QUARTER RATING AT 56%.
THIS 11 POINT DECLINE IS LARGER
THAN ANY PRIOR PRESIDENT
REGISTERED BETWEEN FIRST AND
THIRD QUARTERS ALTHOUGH SIMILAR
TO THOSE TO THE LAST THREE
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTS BARACK
OBAMA.
CLINTON AND CARTER.
ABOUT.
>> BRING IN OUR PANEL BEN
DOMENECH PUBLISHER OF THE
FEDERALIST.
HAROLD FORD JR., AND JASON RILEY
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" COLUMNIST
AND SENIOR FELLOW AT THE
MANHATTAN INSTUDY JASON, THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF INCIDENTS THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE HAD TO CLARIFY.
WE POINTED THEM OUT HERE.
THE BORDER THE SITUATION ABOUT
GAS PRICES.
AND MAYBE MOST IMPORTANTLY ABOUT
TAIWAN.
>> YES, THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ISSUES GOING ON HERE.
I WOULD ADD TO THAT BRET, THE
SPENDING DEBATE GOING ON IN
CONGRESS RIGHT NOW.
I THINK JOE BIDEN'S PROBLEM IS
THAT HE IS TRYING TO PRESENT AS
A DEMOCRAT VERSUS REPUBLICAN
ISSUE.
WHEN, IN REALITY, PARTICULARLY
WITH REGARD TO THE SPENDING
BILL, IT'S A DEMOCRAT VS.
DEMOCRAT PROBLEM.
HE CAN'T GET HIS OWN DUCKS IN A
ROW.
AND YOU HAVE A DEBATE GOING ON
BETWEEN PROGRESSIVES IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND MORE
MODERATES IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ON HOW TO SPIN THIS
SPENDING BILL THAT THEY WANT TO
UNLEASH AND FRANKLY BOILS DOWN
TO AMBITIONS BEING GREATER THAN
THEIR ACTUAL MANDATE THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DID NOT ELECT A
PROGRESSIVE PRESIDENT TO PURSUE
A PROGRESSIVE AGENDA AND BIDEN
IS TRYING TO SLIP ONE BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Bret: "THE WASHINGTON POST,"
HAROLD, WRITES IT THIS WAY ABOUT
THAT TOWN HALL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD ONE CENTRAL
MESSAGE FOR DISAPPOINTED
PROGRESSIVES AT HIS CNN TOWN
HALL LAST NIGHT PLEASE BE
PATIENT.
THE PROBLEM WITH BIDEN'S
PROMISES TO COME BACK TO
PROGRESSIVE PRIORITIES IS THAT
HIS RAZOR THIN DEMOCRATIC
MAJORITIES IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE WON'T BE ANY BIGGER AND
REPUBLICANS WON'T BE ANY MORE
INCLINED TO GO ALONG WHICH IS
WHY PROGRESSIVES HAVE BEEN
URGING HIM FOR MONTHS TO FIGHT
TO GET RID OF THE FILIBUSTER.
SOMETHING HE SAID HE MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE FOR NOW.
>> WELL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON.
THIS IS, I THINK JASON NAILED IT
WITH THE FRAME PROGRESSIVES
DIDN'T AND DON'T HAVE A MASSIVE
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE OR EVEN A
COMFORTABLE MAJORITY IN THE
HOUSE FOR THAT MATTER THE
SENATE.
I THINK WHEN WE ELECTED
PRESIDENT BIDEN, THE COUNTRY
DID, THEY WERE ELECTING SOMEONE
THEY THOUGHT WOULD BRING A LEVEL
OF STABILITY AND MATURITY AND
EXPERIENCE TO THE
DECISION-MAKING AND TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
AND TO JASON'S POINT, THE
PRESIDENT HAS SPENT MOST OF HIS
TIME TRYING TO REFEREE DISPUTES
BETWEEN AND AMONGST HIS OWN
PARTY MEMBERS.
I HAVE SAID FOR SOME TIME,
DEMOCRATS TAKE THE VICTORY.
GIVE THE COUNTRY WHAT THEY HAVE
ASKED FOR WHICH IS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
DEMONSTRATE THAT YOU CAN GOVERN
AND LEAD AND COME BACK AND DO
THE OTHER THINGS.
I THINK AT SOME POINT PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS GOING TO HAVE TO SAY TO
DEMOCRATS IN A FORTHRIGHT WAY, I
HOPE HE DOESN'T HAVE TO SAY IN A
FORTHRIGHT WAY WITH AN OUTCOME
IN VIRGINIA THAT IS DETRIMENTAL
TO MY PARTY.
TERRY McAULIFFE HAS ASKED FOR
DEMOCRATS TO GIVE US VICTORY AND
GIVE US A CHANCE TO LEAD IN THE
GOVERNOR AND LEAD MAJORITY WHICH
IS THE WAY YOU ACTUALLY ENACT
POLICY.
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE HARD
FOR MY PARTY.
>> Bret: I DON'T SEE HOW IT'S
GOING TO GET DONE BEFORE THAT
VIRGINIA ELECTION.
WE WILL SEE.
THEY MAY TRY TO PUT THE PEDAL TO
THE METAL THERE SEEMS LIKE BIG
STICKING POINTS.
I MENTIONED THE FILIBUSTER
CHANGE AND THE EVOLUTION OF THE
PRESIDENT HOW HE HAS TALKED
ABOUT IT TAKE A LISTEN TO THAT
EVOLUTION.
>> I'M TRYING TO BRING THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER AND I DON'T
WANT THE DEBATE TO ONLY BE ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT WE HAVE A
FILIBUSTER.
>> IF IT'S A RELIC OF JIM CROW
IT'S BEEN USED TO DIVIDE CIVIL
RIGHTS LEGISLATION HISTORICALLY
WHY PROTECT IT?
>> NO REASON TO PROTECT IT OTHER
THAN YOU ARE GOING TO TRY THE
THROW THE ENTIRE CONGRESS INTO
CHAOS AND NOTHING WILL GET DONE.
NOTHING AT ALL WILL GET DONE.
AND THERE IS A LOT THE STAKE.
I HAVE ALSO THINK WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO MOVE TO THE POINT
WHERE WE FUNDAMENTALLY ALTER THE
FILIBUSTER.
THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
EXACTLY WHAT THAT MEANS IN TERMS
OF FUNDAMENTALLY ALTERING IT,
WHETHER OR NOT WE JUST END THE
FILIBUSTER STRAIGHT UP.
>> Bret: THAT'S QUITE AN
EVOLUTION, BEN.
>> HOW DIFFERENT YOUR ATTITUDE
IS WHEN YOU MOVE FROM THE SENATE
TO THE WHITE HOUSE TOWARD THE
FILIBUSTER YOU KNOW AND
ESSENTIAL DEFENSE OF AMERICAN
REPRESENTATIVE POLITICS OR JUST
A NUISANCE TO BE WIPED AWAY.
LOOK, I THINK THAT WHAT HAROLD
SAID IS CORRECT IN THE SENSE
THAT PROGRESSIVES DON'T HAVE A
MAJORITY HERE.
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE ANYTHING
CLOSE TO IT.
AND, YET, WHAT THIS REPRESENTS,
WHAT THIS MASSIVE SPENDING
PACKAGE REPRESENTS AT THIS POINT
IS AN ATTEMPT TO TRY TO SATISFY
VIRTUALLY EVERY PROGRESSIVE
PRIORITY EVEN IN WAYS THAT ARE
SLOPPY AND DON'T MAKE SENSE FROM
FISCAL POLICY PERSPECTIVES.
IF YOU ADD A SMALLER POLICY
PACKAGE, YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT WAS MORE
PERMANENT, MORE LONGSTANDING,
INSTEAD YOU ARE LIKELY TO END
UP, IF ANYTHING ENDS UP PASSING
AT ALL WITH A PACKAGE THAT IS
MORE EASILY SWEPT AWAY
POTENTIALLY BY A FUTURE
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY.
I THINK THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
REALLY WAKING UP TO THE FACT
THAT WHILE INDIVIDUAL PARTS OF
THIS PLAN MAY TEST WELL WHEN
THEY ARE POLLED AND WHEN THEY'RE
ASKED OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AS A WHOLE, THIS PLAN IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE ALL THAT EXCITED
ABOUT AND THEY DON'T REALLY
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO SATISFY
THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY SEE EVERY
DAY WHEN THIS COMES TO
INFLATION, WHEN IT COMES TO
THEIR POCKETBOOK AND CERTAINLY
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
INCREASINGLY CONTROVERSIAL
ISSUES RELATED TO EDUCATION
WHICH ARE SO KEY IN THIS
VIRGINIA RACE.
>> Bret: JASON I ONLY HAVE A FEW
SECONDS HERE I WAS.
ESSENTIALLY HIS HANDS ARE TIED
AND GAS PRICES ARE GOING UP INTO
NEXT YEAR SAYING A LOT DEPENDS
ON OPEC AND SAUDI ARABIA.
REPUBLICANS WOULD POINT OUT THAT
A LOT THAT HAPPENED IN THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION TO FREE
THE U.S. FROM FOREIGN OIL AND
THAT WE'RE BACK IN THE PLACE WE
WERE BEFORE THAT.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
AND WHAT BIDEN ISN'T TELLING YOU
THAT HIS PROGRESSIVES ARE HAPPY
WITH HIGH ENERGY COSTS TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT PUSHES PEOPLE
TOWARDS RENEWABLES, TOWARDS
GREEN NEW DEAL TYPE POLICIES AND
SO FORTH.
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH FOSSIL
FUEL ENERGY PRICES GOING UP.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DO.
THE VOTERS DO, AND, AGAIN, JOE
BIDEN WAS NOT ELECTED TO
TRANSITION US OFF FOSSIL FUEL
EVEN IF THAT'S WHAT THE
PROGRESSIVES WAN